الهزات الارضيه ظواهر متكرره الحدوث في
تركيا تعود الى وقوع معظم اجزاء تركيا على
الصفيحه الاناضليه التي تتموضع بين
الصفيحه الاوراسيه التي تمثل نسبيا قشره
غير قابله للحركه والصفيحه العربيه التي
تتجه شمالا بمعدل بوصه واحده تقريبا سنويا
يؤدي هذا الى ضغط تركيا التي تقف على عده
خطوط الصدع اكثر خطوط الصدع تدميرا في
تركيا هو خط الصدع شمالي الاناضول حيث
تلتقي صفيحه الاناضول والاوراسيا هذا
ويمتد خط الصدع شمال الاناضول من جنوب
اسطنبول مباشره على طول الطريق الى شمال
شرق تركيا كذلك يمتد خط صدع شرق الاناضول
حوالي 650 كيلو مترا من مرتفعات شرق تركيا
الى البحر المتوسط حيث يتجه جنوبا ويلتقي
في النهايه مع الصدع الكبير الذي يفصل بين
الصفائح الافريقيه والعربيه
ملوك الشيخ العربيه